[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
hallo und guten abend in ein erstaunt
die augen reiben das können wir aktuell
jeden tag ein grüner klimaschutzminister
unterzeichnet heute verträge für gleich
eine ganze reihe von terminals über die
verflüssigtes erdgas zu uns kommen soll
eine technologie die zumindest aktuell
alles andere als grün ist die
deutschland schon jahrzehntelang hätte
haben können aber nicht gewollt hat
jetzt ist alles anders russland hat die
ukraine mit einem krieg überzogen und
deutschland mit einem energieproblemen
und robert habeck ist auch
wirtschaftsminister
und so spricht der grüne politiker fast
flehentlich in richtung von
umweltverbänden die die vorhaben heftig
kritisieren und mit klagen drohen anselm
stern
der grüne bundesminister für energie und
klimaschutz liegt ab in wilhelmshaven
niedersachsen
gewünschter kurs neue gas politik für
deutschland
offizieller baubeginn heute für
sogenannte lng terminals so schnell wie
möglich sollen hier solche riesentanker
festmachen voll mit flüssigerdgas voll
mit der hoffnung auf mehr energie
unabhängigkeit von russland wir haben
eine gute chance das zu schaffen was ich
würde sagen eigentlich in deutschland
unmöglich ist innerhalb von 10 monaten
etwa zehn monaten an allen terminals zu
errichten und es anzuschließen an die
deutsche gasversorgung ein turbo projekt
der ampelkoalition in zitat habeck
lichtgeschwindigkeit soll nun
zurückgedreht werden was jahrzehntelang
so aussah gas kommt aus russland die
energiestrategie der vergangenheit ob
cdu oder spd in zukunft nun hofft die
aktuelle deutsche regierung auf erdgas
etwa aus den usa oder katar im kommenden
winter soll in wilhelmshaven das erste
lng schiff anlegen ist eine wichtige
investition das hätte eigentlich schon
vor zwanzig vor 15 jahren gemacht werden
müssen man hat sich da von deutscher
seite auf russland verlassen und den
fehler gemacht sich in die abhängigkeit
zu begeben aber diese investitionen sind
notwendig zumindest als
brückentechnologie ln sie übersetzt
verflüssigtes erdgas enorme mengen davon
können transportiert werden per schiff
im zielhafen würde aus der flüssigkeit
wieder gas gemacht dass ins netz
gespeist wird über das neu gebaute
terminal und neu gebaute pipelines neben
wilhelmshaven sollen in den kommenden
jahren noch drei weitere lng standorte
in deutschland eröffnet werden wenn man
sich die deutschen terminals anschaut
die in planung sind dann werden die eine
kapazität hier schwanken die angaben
etwas
so zwischen 40 und 60 prozent der
deutschen erdgasimporte aus russland
durchaus ersetzen können raus aus
russlands exporten der wunsch und doch
gibt es enormen widerstand
umweltverbände warnen vor umweltschäden
es gab keine auslegung von unterlagen
keine beteiligung der umweltverbände
und wir befürchten massive auswirkungen
auf das wattenmeer und auf die küste
klimaschädliches erdgas jetzt teuer
eingekauft allen sie schon lange möglich
lange politisch nicht gewollt heute dann
doch noch ein grünes versprechen die lng
terminals sollen irgendwann stadtgas
klimafreundlichen wasserstoff aufnehmen
können alles brauchen wir wasserstoff
ready alles bauen wir so aus dass hier
die zukunft auch über die nächsten 10 15
jahre hinaus entstehen kann von den
versorgungsunternehmen bis zu den
teilplan oder den speichern betreibern
wilhelmshaven die grüne energie
drehscheibe des landes auch das stand
heute in der einladung der ministerien
bis das die realität werden könnte wird
es noch sehr lange dauern wird noch sehr
viel gas in deutschland dringend
gebraucht
ja sascha müller trainer hat da noch
einige zweifel er ist
bundesgeschäftsführer der deutschen
umwelthilfe herr müller kanal schönen
guten abend guten abend esse was ja wir
haben von robert habeck jetzt gehört
umwelthilfe macht es nicht er hat sie
direkt angesprochen klagt nicht dagegen
das war eine bitte des
wirtschaftsministers und sie beinahe
flehentlich werden sie dieser bitte
folge leisten ja wir haben jetzt erst
mal widerspruch eingelegt gegen diesen
vorzeitigen baubeginn das ist ja schon
erstaunlich dass eine industrieanlage
dieser größe ohne jegliche beteiligung
gebaut wird durchgezogen wird mit
erheblichen auswirkungen auf das klima
mit erheblichen auswirkungen auf die
meeres natur und es gibt doch eine ganze
reihe von wirtschaftswissenschaftlern
sich sagen dass wir dieses terminal
vielleicht überhaupt nicht brauchen und
deswegen haben wir erst mal gesagt wir
wollen uns mal die fakten anschauen und
dann beurteilen können ob das wirklich
notwendig ist oder nicht sie haben
widerspruch eingelegt damit geht jetzt
natürlich weitere wertvolle zeit
verloren die deutschland nicht hat ist
das angesichts der lage ein
verantwortungsvoller weg
so lange wird es nicht dauern wir sind
ihre lage des schnell zu lesen schnell
zu bewerten das genehmigungsverfahren
selbst hat vier tage gedauert also
konnte die behörde das offenbar schnell
beurteilen das können wir auch wir
wollen uns einfach anschauen was wäre
denn ein sinnvoller kompromiss zwischen
dem interesse des klimaschutzes des
naturschutzes und natürlich der
energiesicherheit war natürlich auch wir
sind der meinung wir müssen unabhängig
werden von erdgas aus russland
widerspruch eingelegt was passiert denn
wenn dem nicht stattgegeben wird und
davon ist ja möglicherweise sogar
auszugehen denn sie spüren ja diesen
druck den die politik jetzt macht auch
auf die ihre zuständigen behörden gehen
sie dann doch vor gericht und klagen er
ist schauen wir uns erst mal an was da
ans tageslicht kommt ich denke wir
werden zugang zu den akten bekommen
unser interesse ist jetzt nicht das vor
gericht auszutragen dass es immer erst
der letzte weg uns ist es wichtig ins
gespräch zu kommen darüber wie man diese
terminals wenn man sie denn baut so baut
dass sie möglichst klein sind nur eine
begrenzte zeit laufen und dann
umgestellt werden können auf
erneuerbaren wasserstoff und natürlich
an einem standort wo die meeresumwelt
also beispielsweise der schwer
geschütztes schweinswal nicht bedroht
werden den schweinswal haben sie jetzt
gerade angesprochen sagt robert habeck
ich also eher robert habeck ist der
größte sei der größte schweinswal fan in
der bundesregierung nehmen sie ihm ab
dass er da jetzt aktuell in einer
notsituation ist aus der es eben keinen
perfekten weg raus gibt
natürlich gibt es in dieser krise keine
perfekte lösung wir sind alle
erschüttert über den krieg in der
ukraine und natürlich müssen wir uns
unabhängig machen von russischem gas von
russischem öl von russischer kohle das
wurde jetzt auch jahrzehnte verschlafen
was wir uns wünschen ist dass die
bundesregierung konsequent auf
erneuerbare energien setzt dass sie auch
konsequent auf energiesparen setzt
energie sparen würde sofort wirken da
fehlt uns ein bisschen die
geschwindigkeit von der bundesregierung
da haben wir noch keinen konkreten
vorschläge gehört natürlich muss müssen
jetzt hier schwierige entscheidung
getroffen werden aber doch nicht immer
auf kosten der natur
ist es am ende so dass es unterm strich
auf eine rechnung die ich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen überspitzt
darstellen hinausläuft auf der einen
seite die potenzielle gefährdung von
schweinswalen auf der anderen seite die
potenzielle gefährdung von großen teilen
der deutschen wirtschaft und der
mögliche verlust von hunderttausenden
von arbeitsplätzen
also werden wir diese terminals brauchen
dann müssen die natürlich schnell gebaut
werden aber dann sollten wir wirklich
nur so viele bauen wie wir brauchen und
dann müssen wir natürlich wie bei allen
anderen großen industrieanlagen darauf
achten dass die negativen auswirkungen
auf die natur gerade auf die gefährte
meeres natur und auf gefährdete arten
wie den schweinswal so minimal gehalten
werden wie möglich dazu müssen wir erst
mal die planungsunterlagen sehen die
haben wir bisher nicht gesehen das ist
bisher in völlig geschlossenes geheimnis
verfahren so etwas gehört sich in einem
rechtsstaat eigentlich nicht geben sie
uns doch bitte noch eine zeitachse so
ein bisschen so einen ausblick was
glauben sie werden am ende in ende
dieses jahres anfang nächsten jahres die
ersten terminals tatsächlich in betrieb
gehen können so wie das jetzt geplant
worden ist von der politik
also herr beck hat ja gesagt das sollen
jetzt erstmal floating terminals eno ich
schwimmen schwimmen der terminals
eingekauft werden hat die
bundesregierung glaube ich auch schon
gemacht und das sind jetzt terminals
wenn die jetzt für ein paar jahre
wirklich installiert werden danach
wieder abgebaut werden ersetzt werden
durch erneuerbare energien wenn man das
am richtigen standort macht dann kann
man das sicher darüber reden damit wir
das größte problem haben ist das jetzt
hier anlagen stationär gebaut werden
beispielsweise in brunsbüttel
beispielsweise in wilhelmshaven die dann
die nächsten 20 30 jahre dastehen geld
verdienen müssen dann können wir unsere
klimaziele in den wind schreiben die
deutsche umwelthilfe hat noch einige
fragen das war der bundesgeschäftsführer
einer der bundesgeschäftsführer sascha
aumüller krenner herzlichen dank für das
gespräch heute abend hier im heute
journal dankeschön
und damit sind wir bei unserem nächsten
thema heute abend das zerwürfnis hat nie
so wirklich in die zeit gepasst schon
gar nicht in einer in der ein krieg tobt
es hat trotzdem für mächtig wirbel
gesorgt für kanzler worte und
oppositionskritik aber jetzt sind die
zitat
irritationen der vergangenheit
ausgeräumt wie das bundespräsidialamt in
schönstem polit deutsch mitteilt der
bundespräsident hat nach dem hin und her
um seinen besuch in kiew mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten telefoniert und
hat dabei auch eine einladung nach kiew
erhalten die bundes außenministerin wird
schon bald fahren wie wichtig ukrainisch
deutsche verständigung ist zeigt auch
die tatsache dass die ukrainerin deren
schicksal wir ihnen jetzt zeigen unserer
reporterin sofort mit dem wunsch kam sie
würde am liebsten vor dem bundestag
sprechen über das was ihr widerfahren
ist katrin eigendorf berichtet hanna
polonski will wieder gehen lernen doch
ob sie jemals wieder durch einen wald
joggen wird wie sie es bis vor zwei
monaten noch gerne tat weiß niemand
hannah war mit ihrem mann und ihrem hund
im auto auf der flucht aus butter als
sie von russischen soldaten angegriffen
wurden
sofort nur fotos sind geblieben aus
einem leben das nun in trümmern liegt es
gibt nicht einmal ein grab von anton
seine leiche wurde nie gefunden nur das
zerschossene auto und die koffer und
kisten die sie hastig für die flucht
gepackt hatten
der schmerz ist so groß dass hanna
versucht nicht daran zu denken sie hat
nicht nur ihren mann verloren ich war
noch schwanger
leider habe ich das kunst verloren ich
habe auf einen gewartet und so und es
ist wirklich schrecklich aber
jetzt denke ich nur über meine
gesundheit ich möchte wieder imstande
sein
mit meinen eigenen beinen und füßen zu
gehen hier in butter wollten sie leben
anton und hannas traum vom kleinen glück
mit kind und hund in einem schönen
vorort von kiew er wurde von putins
armee für so viele zerstört heute ist
butscher symbol für tausendfachen mord
an zivilisten dass hanna überlebt hat
ist ein kleines wunder
die ersten 24 stunden konnte ich nicht
operiert werden wegen der
bombardierungen und ich bin einfach in
einem
krankenhaus in japan geblieben im keller
im keller über den fluss von dem
gefährlichen fluchtweg für tausende
zivilisten trugen vier männer die
schwerverletzte hanna am 9 märz raus aus
der stadt in ihrem zimmer gibt hanna
heute online unterricht sie ist
deutschlehrerin jede ablenkung tut ihr
gut sagt die 32 jährige empfindet sie
hass gegenüber russland
auch für jeden tag auf das ende dieses
krieges ich hoffe darauf dass es wieder
möglich wird uns zu kommunizieren und zu
unterhalten ich meine unsere völker und
den hass empfinde ich nicht weil es ein
falscher weg ist dann hast du im
internet
hannahs wunsch sie möchte vor den
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
sprechen ihre geschichte so glaubt sie
ist die geschichte der ukraine
der bundestag hätte einiges zu erfahren
ein schicksal von so vielen aktuell in
der ukraine
weitere wichtige nachrichten zum thema
hast du jetzt und dabei geht es um eine
menge geld das der ukraine heute
zumindest zugesagt wurde mehr als sechs
milliarden euro das ist das ergebnis der
zweiten internationalen geberkonferenz
für die ukraine polen und schweden
hatten dazu eingeladen
deutschland will sich mit zusätzlichen
125 millionen euro beteiligen und
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
kündigte ein neues eu hilfspaket in höhe
von 200 millionen euro an zudem
versprach eu ratspräsidenten michelle
kiew dem wiederaufbau des landes nach
einem sogenannten europäischen
marshallplan
russlands präsident putin hat sich laut
israel für einen nazi-vergleich seines
außenministers lavrov entschuldigt und
zwar in einem telefonat mit dem
israelischen ministerpräsidenten
benjamin
vom kreml gibt es bisher keine
bestätigung
hintergrund ist eine aussage love rocks
in bezug auf den ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky lavrov hatte gesagt
das zitat die eifrigsten antisemiten in
der regel juden seien und behauptet auch
hitler habe jüdisches blut gehabt
bei einem anschlag in israel sind
mindestens drei menschen getötet worden
vier weitere sollen laut
rettungsdiensten verletzt worden sein
die tat ereignete sich in der streng
religiösen ortschaft ängstlich von tel
aviv in der umgebung wurden laut polizei
straßensperren errichtet ein helikopter
kreiste über der gegend israel wird seit
wochen von einer serie anti-israelischer
anschläge erschüttert
mehr als jeder fünfte in deutschland war
schon einmal selbst von rassismus
betroffen das ist ein ergebnis der
auftakt studie zu einem neuen nationalen
diskriminierung und rassismus monitor
zudem gaben 45 prozent der befragten an
rassistische vorfälle bereits selbst
beobachtet zu haben
rassismus sei alltag in deutschland
sagte die direktorin des deutschen
zentrums für integrations- und
migrationsforschung nach der auftakt
studie soll es nun weitere befragungen
geben
im vereinigten königreich stimmen die
bürgerinnen und bürger heute über
gemeinde- und bezirksräte ab ein
wichtiger stimmungstest für
premierminister johnson im nordirland
könnte die pro-irische schimpfen
stärkste partei im regionalparlament
werden es würde die macht balance nach
dem friedens beschluss von 1998
empfindlich stören
bei einer schießerei auf offener straße
sind gestern abend in duisburg vier
menschen verletzt worden das motiv ist
bislang unklar
laut ermittlern waren rocker der hells
angels und mitglieder eines kriminellen
türkisch arabischen clans in den streit
geraten bis zu 100 menschen sollen an
der auseinandersetzung beteiligt gewesen
sein 15 personen wurden festgenommen
die polizei bittet zeugen um fotos und
videos zur klärung des tathergangs
an diesem sonntag steht nummer zwei an
nummer zwei von vier geplanten
landtagswahlen in diesem jahr hoch im
norden wählt schleswig holstein einen
neuen landtag und sagen wir mal so ein
wechsel wind ist an den küsten dort
nicht zu spüren ministerpräsident daniel
günther regiert seit fünf jahren mit
einer koalition aus seiner cdu und
grünen und fdp jamaika in kiel er selbst
hat gute werte und wenn man sich jetzt
mal ganz frisch von heute abend das
letzte zdf politbarometer vor der wahl
anguckt dann heißt die überschrift
kontinuität demnach käme die cdu aktuell
auf 38 prozent der stimmen und bleibt
stärkste partei was sie da unten kleinen
sehen übrigens ist die veränderung zur
letzten umfrage vor einer woche im
vergleich zur letzten wahl könnte die
cdu ihren vorsprung erheblich ausbauen
gefolgt von der spd mit 18 prozent und
auch die grünen kämen derzeit auf 18
prozent
die fdp bei 8 prozent die fdp würde mit
sechs prozent den einzug schaffen der
südschleswigsche wählerverband käme
ebenfalls auf sechs prozent vom
wahlkampf im norden berichtet aus kiel
hannah hebestreit es sind diese sitze um
dieses bei der landtagswahl in
schleswig-holstein geht das gestühl
musste vorübergehend weichen für den
aufbau des zdf wahlstudio im plenarsaal
hier wird man am sonntag erfahren wer
für die regierungsbank in frage kommt
und wem die opposition winkt
ministerpräsident daniel günther von der
cdu würde für weitere fünf jahre gerne
zu kurs halten unter dem eindruck des
ukraine krieges wille punkten mit den
erfolgen der von ihm geführten
jamaika-koalition
jetzt merken wir wie richtig es war auf
erneuerbare energien zu setzen wir haben
den grünen strom bei uns in schleswig
holstein wir können mithelfen auch die
versorgung und die abhängigkeit von
russland zu beenden für cdu grüne und
fdp könnte der wahltag allerdings das
ende ihrer im land durchaus populären
jamaika koalition bringen nach umfragen
braucht es so noch zwei
koalitionspartner und so beginnt im
endenden dreierbündnis das buhlen um den
platz an günter seite diese jamaika
regierung ist beliebt auf dem
stimmzettel gibt es aber nicht dass
jamaika fähnchen wer den
ministerpräsidenten wählt wählt cdu
wählt konservativ und krieg zum schluss
möglicherweise schwarz gelb eine reise
in die vergangenheit die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben jetzt diese wunderbare
chance wenn wir da jamaika zu bestätigen
wenn das ergebnis so ist oder sie müssen
einen der partner auswählen wer dann
tatsächlich auch mit daniel runter
gemeinsam reagieren
und ehrlich ich finde das sehr
demokratische entscheidung wir machen
klar dass es um diese entscheidung geht
die nord fdp schließt eine
ampelkoalition mit grünen und der spd
aus sollte der vorsprung der union
tatsächlich so groß werden wie
prognostiziert
das verringert seine optionen
ministerpräsident zu werden
spd-spitzenkandidat thomas müller bleibt
nur sich mit unterstützung erfolgreicher
parteiprominenz in eine gute
ausgangsposition zu bringen es ist kein
einfacher wahlkampf in dem sinne dass es
viele themen gibt die auch die
landesthemen überlagern umso besonderer
dass die menschen auch die landesthemen
wirklich interessieren sich natürlich
auch daran energiepreise steigen jetzt
deswegen ist das thema entlastung von
familien die gebührenfreie kita ein
großes thema auch vom abschneiden des
ssw hängt es am ende ab ob es
tatsächlich zwei oder doch drei
koalitionspartner braucht die vertretung
der dänischen minderheit ist von der
fünf prozent hürde befreit dürfte also
sehr wahrscheinlich ins parlament
einziehen letzte umfragen machen der afg
ebenfalls hoffnung auf einen
wiedereinzug in den landtag trotz
massiver parteiinterne
auseinandersetzungen auch hier im norden
wie das werben um die meisten stimmen
ausgeht erfahren sie am sonntag im zdf
wahlstudio live aus dem landtag an der
kieler förde
ja diese großartigen zdf wagen sind
bereits bereit der krieg gegen die
ukraine hat jetzt bereits einige
gewinner und zwar in der wirtschaft dies
vermutlich selbst nicht glauben können
wenn sie sich plötzlich ihre
zuwachsraten angucken auf dem konto anna
christie an das kann man so sagen die
kassen klingeln und zwar bei den
mineralölkonzernen shell vermeldet heute
einen rekordgewinn von 6,7 milliarden
euro das sind 26 prozent mehr als im
vorjahresquartal und damit ist das
unternehmen nicht allein in der branche
frank bethmann in frankfurt warum
profitieren die konzerne so stark von
diesem krieg na weil dadurch durch die
unsicherheit die ölpreise enorm
gestiegen sind und die ölmultis die das
öl ja fördern zuletzt dieses teuer
verkaufen konnten bei im prinzip mehr
oder weniger gleichbleibenden kosten das
und die im vergangenen jahr historischen
verluste der ölkonzerne erklären nun
ihre gewaltigen gewinnsprünge schnell
verkündete heute nur für die ersten drei
monate des jahres diesen gewinn von 6,7
milliarden euro verglichen mit dem
vorjahresquartal
die französische total energie und der
eso konzern exxon mobil mit jeweils um
die fünf milliarden euro + das comeback
der ölkonzerne kaum noch für möglich
gehalten auch weil sich die sicht auf
die dinge dramatisch geändert hat der
ukraine krieg hat das thema klimaschutz
in den hintergrund und da für die
energiesicherheit in den vordergrund
gedrängt und sorgen diese rekordgewinne
durchaus für kritik italien besteuert
die extragewinne bereits höher hier wird
das in deutschland diskutiert naja da
liebäugelt man auch mit der
italienischen sonderbesteuerung die
verbraucherschützer argumentieren die
öl- und gaskonzerne dürften sich durch
die energie krise nicht auf kosten der
verbraucher bereichern auch bei den
grünen findet die extrasteuer anklang
die fdp aber bremst die konzerne sollen
diese üppigen gewinne lieber in den
klimawandel investieren und so ein wenig
geht bei der ganzen diskussion unter
dass der staat ja schon jetzt mit
verdient nämlich durch die
mineralölsteuer
vielen dank nach frankfurt
die wirecard insolvenz ist einer der
größten wirtschaftsskandale der
bundesrepublik und hat das landgericht
münchen die bilanzen des konzerns
nachträglich für nichtig erklärt konkret
geht es um die jahre 2017 und 18 geklagt
hatte der insolvenzverwalter das urteil
könnte auch für die aktionäre des
konzerns weitreichende folgen haben
ihnen drohten möglicherweise die
rückzahlung der damals ausgeschütteten
dividenden in höhe von 47 millionen euro
außerdem sind jetzt die erfolgschancen
für klagen gegen den damaligen
wirtschaftsprüfer iii gestiegen dieser
hatte die bilanzen für korrekt erklärt
nach sechs monaten im weltall ist der
deutsche astronauten matthias maurer auf
dem rückweg zur erde zusammen mit drei
us-astronauten dockte er um kurz vor
halb acht heute am morgen von der
raumstation iss ab während seiner
mission cosmic ist hatte er in den
bereichen physik biologie medizin und
künstliche intelligenz geforscht die
rückreise zur erde dauert fast 24
stunden und soll morgen früh im wasser
vor der küste floridas enden die landung
können sie ab 6 uhr 15 bei zdf heute
live verfolgen
615 wecker stellen nicht vergessen so
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
mir reicht zum abschalten und entspannen
im grunde ein einziger blick auf dieses
mal wilde mal komplett stille große
tiefe blau
auf diese perfekte linie am horizont
merken sie schon was
gerne
das wirkt
und jetzt dazu noch der sound des meeres
denn die ozeane sind der größte und
klang reichste lebensraum auf unserem
planeten er ist fantastisch und er ist
in gefahr stephan merseburger nimmt uns
mit ziemlich weit weg vom großen mehr in
die große stadt an der spree wo sie von
e weltpremiere hat und was das ist muss
man sehen und hören
eintauchen in die ozeane die reise geht
von pol zu pol man ist eingeladen sich
zu verlieren in der unterwasserwelt zu
verweilen in der tiefe da wo es kaum
noch licht gibt wo es auf das gehirn
kommt sie verheißt dieses erlebbare
kunst wirklich hart wird für uns
menschen ist das schwer vorstellbar
stellen sie sich vor in die dunkelheit
abzutauchen wir orientieren uns
maßgeblich mit den augen meerestiere
dagegen machen das mit geräuschen und
vibrationen
der britische sound künstler chris
watson ist der schöpfer dieser unter
wasser sind seit jahrzehnten reist der
rund um den erdball um den klang der
natur einzufangen
er ist der weltweit führende spezialist
für solche aufnahmen
den visuellen teil der installation hat
die berliner lichtkünstlerin theresa
baumgartner gestalt ich bin selber sehr
interessant
sachen über eine emotionale ebene zu
erklären und über ein erlebnis
verständlich zu machen
doch die meere sind voller disharmonie
mensch gemacht eisbrecher und
frachtschiff amma das sind unterwegs
bohrinseln fördern kostbare rohstoffe
die meeresbewohner leiden unter lärm
verschmutzung
die tiere das gehör verlieren verlieren
sie auch ihre orientierung ihre
fähigkeit zu kommunizieren nahrung und
einen partner zu finden es ist
gefährlich für sie und wir begreifen
erst allmählich das ausmaß der schäden
das lärmverschmutzung anrichtet
auch in der installation wir bauen geht
es um die entfremdung von mensch und
natur michelle marino je schickt uns via
virtual reality in das bewusstsein eines
wild und eines zuchtlachse
der eine wechseln freiheit auf der
andere ein gefecht im käfig
kino kino wir müssen doch nur auf die
indigenen kulturen gucken
sie schaffen es seit jahrtausenden im
gleichgewicht mit der natur zu leben
eine klebrige tun denn
chris watson glaubt an den technischen
fortschritt und alternative energien
containerschiffe etwa die von segeln
stadt von dieselmotoren angetrieben
werden naja ich bin eher optimistisch
denn das entscheidende bei der lärm
verschmutzung ist wenn der lärm weg ist
ist die verschmutzung vorbei anders als
bei chemie oder plastik diese schäden
bleiben für jahrzehnte
so ist der ozean ganz ohne verschmutzung
faszinierend und schützen
wie wenig passend dass wir diesen
planeten erde nennen hat mal jemand
geschrieben wenn er doch ganz klar ozean
ist
das war unsere welt an diesem donnerstag
ich lege ihnen die kollegin maybrit
illner natürlich noch ans herz gleich
nach uns frieden schaffen mit noch mehr
waffen fehler oder pflicht das wird eine
sehr spannende runde und außerdem
empfehlen wir ihnen noch unser
heute-journal update gegen 0 uhr 30 mit
nazan charakter mir von unseren hier an
sie einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter im april war der
regen sehr unterschiedlich verteilt und
das zeigt unsere karte hier vom
deutschen wetterdienst nach osten war es
sehr trocken das sind diese rolle
bräunlichen farben teils bis zu 85
prozent weniger regen oder schnee als
normalerweise üblich dafür was zwischen
donau und main sehr nass und da gab es
sogar 100 bis sogar 200 regen schauen
wir auf den aktuellen regen den gibt es
durchaus an den alpen und zwar dieses
tief hier das schaufelt feuchte luft in
den süden deutschlands und da gibt es
schauer und gewitter in der nacht also
im süden kompakte wolken mit regen sonst
klart es auf teilweise bildet sich nebel
vor allem der nähe von gewässern und das
bei tiefsten temperaturen von 3 grad in
der norddeutschen tiefebene und 10 grad
zum beispiel in bayern morgen dann
südlich der donau viele wolken schauer
und gewitter hier dabei ansonsten aber
aufgelockert und trocken und mit
sonnigen abschnitten das bei höchsten
temperaturen von 14 grad am alpenrand
und 23 grad im rhein-main-gebiet jesus
am wärmsten ansonsten häufig werte um
die 20 grad marke blick auf die nächsten
tage einige schauer gibt es am samstag
es wird nicht viel sein im süden
ebenfalls 14 bis 23 grad sonntag eine
gewisse schauer und gewitterneigung bei
24 grad und montag deutlich trockener
und 25 grad ein schöner